there was a period of time when pop-up
ads were a scourge of the internet and
now most browsers just blocked pop-ups
by default and consumers hate pop-up ads
and so they stop being used on all
mainstream sites and so on so if the ads
that people are doing our intrusive and
annoying then it tends to push people to
install ad blocking software but if the
ads are relevant and not too annoying
and show up at a time when they make
sense then people won't block them and
so I'm not worried about some
apocalyptic decline of had supported
websites because everybody blocks the
ads I just don't think that's likely to
happen do you think it's an apple attack
on google search revenues it's that's a
really good question I you would never
say well why would Apple do such a thing
if they think it's very advantageous I'm
sure that they will have done it I'm not
sure it's a good question I don't know
if it came primarily from consumer
demand or if it came primarily from that
it's it's hard to say anyone and
everyone can contribute to Wikipedia
they can write on the Encyclopedia pages
but that also means that it's not always
factually correct I read on your own
Wikipedia page that in the early days
you were so concerned about this
open-air policy that you used to get up
in the middle of the night and monitor
and log in and see what people were
writing is that true and how did you
ever get to resolve that well so in the
early days you know we're talking a
handful of people editing and mostly
during sort of us extended US time zones
and I would worry what happens when the
people in you know the last time zone go
to bed and are the Australians going to
behave themselves overnight like only
just check just start might take a few
few minutes just to check turned out it
wasn't a big issue we never really had a
huge problem and as it turns out one
interesting about communities if if the
software is right and if it's done right
community is inherently scale so the
more people you have on the community
monitoring each other then well what if
a lot of people come out from Australia
in the middle of night when i'm asleep
well they'll look
after each other and so that's kind of
the Wikipedia principle
do you have any fears or
sounds about the future in your industry
yeah I mean there are things that I
think we all need to keep an eye on I'm
concerned about this increasing idea of
local internet sovereignty so when you
hear the the Chinese the Russians
talking about the need for sovereignty
over their own internet what they really
mean is they want more ability to
control and manipulate the internet for
their own advantage
you've spoken a lot about cybersecurity
it's been documented that you've got a
lot of views on that and we're all
familiar with claims made by the likes
of Snowden for example in light of that
do you think anyone can ever really
expect any information they put online
to remain private in any capacity well I
think we have a really strong interest
in trying really hard but on a personal
level I always recommend to people
assume that anything that you put into
digital format is vulnerable even if
it's a text or what's that message yeah
i mean just assume just it's the safest
thing to do it's sort of like it's it's
excessive but it's sort of like i have
an assumption that if I see a mushroom
growing in the wild it's probably going
to kill me if I eat it not completely
true but I don't have the expertise to
know
people should they should reflect on it
they should think about it and they
should understand that you know the
biggest potential attack vector you
might have is probably not the NSA it's
your friend forwarding the email that
you shouldn't have written and that sort
of thing and so behaving yourself online
is always a good idea
do you think the government is quite
naive when it comes to encryption and
security I see government's not
understanding technology very well and
so they assume there are policy options
on the table which don't exist and you
know to say ban in to end encryption is
like saying well it's bad math because
it's very straightforward mathematics
the software is already out there freely
shared online you know it's you can't
ban it it's just not going to happen so
that's not a policy option so anybody
who proposes that as policy option you
immediately know Oh actually you don't
know anything about technology like you
have no idea what you're talking about
so what kind of government do because
they you know they need to be able to
spy on potential terrorists well I mean
there are things they can do good
old-fashioned police work you know not
it's sort of the world hasn't changed as
much as they would like us to think they
have the bad guys have always managed to
talk to each other in private you know
when you know go for go for a walk in
Hyde Park and have a private
conversation and that's always been
possible and always will be and as we
have different levels of security online
the bad guys will always gravitate to
secure technologies and it just means
that as of just a fact of reality just
as the police can't know what you say in
your living room at home to your friend
they can't know what you say just
because your friends across town and
you've texted using a C or chat app so
it's overblown the need for this is ben
much overblown